dr. strange is a very specific kind of
superhero instead of patrolling the city
for muggers or bank robbers
he fights demons and warlords from other
dimensions and deals with the
manifestations of otherwise abstract
concepts like eternity and death but
while his bizarre mind-bending
adventures have made him one of the
weirder characters in the Marvel
Universe the good doctor has left huge
footprints on the cultural landscape
from Steve Ditko's psychedelic extra
dimensional landscapes to his numerous
connections to the world of rock and
roll here's the truth behind dr. Stephen
strange who wants to live forever in
1974 is Doctor Strange number four the
sorcerer battles death literally inside
the orb of agamotto Doctor Strange is
confronted with the character death the
same skeletal woman whose tender
affections have always been craved by
Thanos strange fights hard to free
himself but ultimately recalls the
ancient ones teachings about how death
is just another part of life after
letting death overcome him he awakens to
find that this was merely the first in a
series of trials that he must confront
as the sorcerer supreme as a result of
his surrender to death Doctor Strange is
now actually ageless he can still die
but only from being killed by others as
far as natural causes are concerned
he'll be around after most of us are
dust playing cards with Thor and
Wolverine the sorcerer supreme versus
Amy Grant in 1986 Christian singer Amy
Grant released a greatest hits
compilation titled
the collection four years later a Marvel
Comics artist decided Amy Grant could
look a lot like a vampire the similarity
did not go unnoticed and Amy Grant's
managers brought Marvel Comics to court
their complaints cited the comics
connections to witchcraft and beard cult
and how associating Amy Grant was such a
comic could do irreparable injury to her
reputation among Christian fans the two
parties settled in 1991 and while we
don't know the terms of the agreement we
do know one thing if you look up the
digital version of Doctor Strange
sorcerer supreme number 15 today you'll
find an empty red background replacing
Amy Grant's perón face too many zeros in
2012 the New York Post tried to speak to
Steve Ditko the creator of Doctor
Strange and co-creator of spider-man it
didn't work out main
because Ditko is legendarily averse to
talking to the media he did however
answer one question when they asked if
he received any money for any of the
spider-man films that have been released
up to that point he simply said no but
that might not be entirely accurate in
2016 Abraham Riesman stalked out Steve
Ditko's Manhattan studio hoping to get a
few words with the reclusive creator the
best he managed was to get Ditko to
answer his studio door which did cope
promptly shut again after shaking his
head and what Riesman describes as
disgust
he had more luck with other people with
offices in the building including one
unnamed woman who said she'd mistakenly
received a cheque meant for Ditko which
he realized wasn't hers when it had
quote too many zeroes if the story is
true that could mean there is some kind
of agreement between Ditko and Sony or
Marvel Studios and if it's not
spider-man the most likely candidate is
the sorcerer supreme dr. strange is cool
with dr. strange while Steve Ditko might
not want anything to do with the film
adaptations of his creations at least
one of his creations feels differently
in the unbelievable Guin pool number
three the title character makes an
appointment with dr. strange as a comic
book reader from the real world who
found herself transported to the Marvel
Universe Gwynn has no valid social
security number or other identifying
information to give to her new employer
meaning that she doesn't get paid while
it's not strange his usual problem
making fake IDs for travelers from
another universe is certainly something
he can do when strange peeks into Gwen's
native dimension he discovers the
relationship between the real world and
his own specifically the film based on
his own comics while he might not be
thrilled he definitely seems ok with the
casting choice for the main character
the doctor rocks one of the first things
we learn about Stephen strange in the
2016 film is that he has an encyclopedic
knowledge of modern music but it
shouldn't have come as a surprise since
Doctor Strange has a long history in the
world of rock judging by the covers the
song titles and the lyrics his biggest
impact was on Pink Floyd who used
interior art from strange tales number
158 on the cover to their 1968 album
Saucerful of Secrets it doesn't stop
there t-rex mentioned Doctor Strange and
Mambo Sun on the 1971 album Electric
warrior in
1965 Jefferson Airplane The Charlatans
the Great Society and others appeared on
a handbill for a concert they called a
tribute to dr. strange the price for the
most elaborate tribute to the sorcerer
supreme though has to go to Al Stewart
the album art for 1974 is past present
in the future
in 1975 s modern times both featured dr.
strange leaping into a portal and then
appearing in a flash of light before a
mansion the clothes make the man in 1968
dr. strange took over strange tales as
his own comic but sales began to slump
to shake things up his costume was
altered to a more super heroic look but
the most interesting detail here isn't
the costume itself it's the ridiculous
way it was explained dr. strange number
177 opens was strange and his lover Clea
banished to another dimension by a
villain who mystically disguised himself
in strange his form when strange
attempts to re-enter his own dimension
an unseen mystical barrier stops him
because there's already someone there
who looks like that's right to fool the
magical mystical boundaries of the
universe itself dr. strange casts a
spell that changes his costume and
creates a mask because apparently that's
all it takes maybe he just shoulda tried
glasses the substitute supreme before
Marvel's Netflix Heroes took the name
the comic book defenders were a very
different group with lots and lots of
incarnations while the roster would
change a dozen times over the years dr.
strange was almost always part of the
team which is pretty ironic since writer
Roy Thomas originally didn't want him
involved at all in a 2013 interview
Thomas said he wanted the lineup from a
story he wrote called Titans 3 with the
Hulk named arc and the Silver Surfer
unfortunately for Thomas Stanley was
very protective with the Silver Surfer
and hadn't been thrilled by Titans 3 to
match the surfers cosmic power he
suggested that Thomas used dr. strange
instead which is exactly what he did in
Marvel feature issue number 1 this time
it seems Lia proved once the defenders
got their own title a few months later
the Silver Surfer joined the team and
issue number 2 Galactus by the way
Doctor Strange is powerful so powerful
that even Galactus
the devourer of worlds is no problem at
all well that might be an exaggeration
but when the Avengers and Fantastic Four
can bind forces against Galactus dr.
strange was the one who turned the tide
with a spell that froze the devourer in
his tracks the heroes took advantage and
once the smoke cleared the sorcerer
revealed that the spell he cast forced
Galactus to confront the ghosts of all
those he has slain considering Galactus
has destroyed entire worlds it's easy to
see why this particular tactic was
effective thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel let's check out all this cool
stuff we know you love to